now well it is national hot chocolate
day and in honor of that we're making a
version of hot chocolate it's actually
drinking chocolate and I'm joined by
pastry chef in Ming Shu co-owner of Sip
and we're going to be trying some of
this delicious smelling drinking
chocolate good morning so nice to have
you thank you for having me I'm learning
a lot while we've been talking during
the break and so I what I understand is
that we're going to set up our chocolate
and then we get to put all these little
goodies in it this is so popular right
now this is a hot chocolate bar okay so
you can put anything great for families
all right if you have kids put anything
that you want in it don't put anything
at all in it I've got Randy and I've got
they're not opened by the way dog on it
I'm kidding so what's the best part for
the adults let's pour a little let's see
it and then tell me about the art of
chocolate you're a you're a towel
talented pastry chef and your business
was born out of the pandemic so and then
tell me how it's taken off since then we
are primarily an e-commerce business
okay so this business I'm partnered with
my sister okay so she's in New Mexico
but we do
three flavors of the mix we do
um dark chocolate milk chocolate and
peppermint can I put anything in it you
can put anything and this is which one
is this this is the milk chocolate okay
sorry you can peppermint is a favorite
peppermint so the crushed peppermint yes
peppermint so I love the bar the way
it's set up but you said this is an
e-commerce business so do people order
the ingredients and then they order the
mix so we sell packets of mix here okay
I also do wholesale so if you go have
hot chocolate at the win you're going to
be having our sip chocolate oh
the local stadiums also have
um so like Allegiant and yes oh my
goodness so they use it for special
occasions for for the VIP boxes things
like that this is absolutely beautiful
it is so elegant what is it about
sipping chocolate drinking chocolate
that's different drinking chocolate is
not the same as hot cocoa so we are used
to hot cocoa here yes in America it's
cocoa powder okay cocoa powder
drinking chocolate is chocolate it's
very similar to Hot Chocolate so
somebody says hot chocolate hot
chocolate is different from cocoa powder
the hot cocoa okay so drinking chocolate
European style a little bit richer
creamier it is and you can tell it's
thicker it's much richer it's delicious
so that like a little bit of whipped
cream just really just well I don't mind
if I do you're gonna insist on whipped
cream I shall so but it's it's a
different it's slightly different
it's not anything that we invented okay
but not a lot of people know about
drinking it's elegant in me it's elegant
where can people find your sip online
can they order it and your pastries
which look delicious that's made with
best made with the Sip really okay so we
I like to call this multi-purpose all
right so I made some brownies I made
some chocolate almond cookies The
Filling is a chocolate cream that's made
with the Sip also so so it's delicious
in the summer frozen hot chocolate
frozen I've heard of it can you make you
make the mix freeze it and put it in
your blender it's it's delicious
absolutely what is one pouch cost just
so we can get 100 20 for price points so
that is sip extraordinary.com is our
website okay but here in Henderson Honey
And Hive Salon K Andrews Salon okay she
sells it honey and Hive well thank you
it is absolutely a pleasure we'll go to
your website you can learn more thank
you uh it's delightful to meet you
really years of experience really the
art of sipping chocolate I have a lot of
research to do we'll be right back I'm
researching now thank you and me you're
delightful thank you really